es handelt sich um einen echten super
laser die rede ist von einem neuen
rekord der laser intensität ein
forschungsteam aus südkorea konnte
erstmals laserpulse mit 100 trilliarden
watt pro quadratzentimeter erzeugen eine
echte rekord intensität die zahlreiche
forschungsbereiche revolutionieren
könnte klicks und future los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in unserem alltag
ist die lasertechnologie schon längst
nicht mehr wegzudenken
man denke beispielsweise an laserdrucker
oder die scannerkassen in den
supermärkten die hologramme aus ec oder
kreditkarten werden mit laserlicht
angefertigt und lasershows in clubs und
diskotheken machen eine party erst so
richtig gut aber nicht nur in solchen
alltags anwendungen sondern vor allem
auch in der wissenschaft sind laser von
enormer wichtigkeit mit hilfe der laser
technologie lassen sich daten
übermitteln und atome kühlen und
einsperren materialien können mit hilfe
von laserstrahlen geschnitten werden der
sogar metall kann mit dem gebündelten
licht getrennt werden auch in der
medizin ist die lasertechnologie nicht
mehr wegzudenken beispielsweise lassen
sich bestimmte arten der sehschwäche mit
einer laseroperation weg laser
forschungsteams weltweit tüfteln daran
laser immer weiter zu optimieren denn um
beispielsweise die vielen rätsel des
kosmos oder der materie zu lüften
braucht es leser die eine extreme
lichtenergie auf sehr kleinem raum
fokussieren denn auch um messungen vom
mikrokosmos bis zu gravitationswellen
durchzuführen braucht es die
lasertechnologie 10 hoch 22 watt also 22
nullen hinter der einst pro
quadratzentimeter so defensiv waren die
bislang stärksten laserpulse die ein us
forschungsteam bereits vor vielen jahren
erzeugen konnte
fachleute aus südkorea haben nun einen
neuen rekord aufgestellt dabei konnten
sie eine intensität von mehr als 10 hoch
23 watt pro quadratzentimeter erreichen
das ist also noch mal 10 mal mehr als
der bisherige rekord die physikerinnen
und physiker sind selbst überrascht von
diesem spektakulären erfolg das
forschungsteam erhofft sich damit
ungeklärter astrophysikalische phänomene
wie beispielsweise die vorgänge um die
mysteriösen schwarzen löcher aufklären
zu können sie
hat dieser laser wird es uns erlauben
neue wissenschaftliche herausforderungen
anzugehen
wir können damit endlich einige
theoretische ideen überprüfen die
teilweise schon vor 100 jahren
aufgestellt worden
doch wie genau konnte diese enorme leser
intensität erzeugt werden und welche
fortschritte in der wissenschaft sind
somit denkbar alle antworten auf diese
spannenden fragen gibt es in diesem
video laser ist eine abkürzung für light
amplification by stimulated emission of
radiation übersetzt also ungefähr so
etwas wie licht verstärkung durch
stimulierte strahlungs emissionen schon
der physiker albert einstein hatte sich
mit dem thema beschäftigt im januar 10
16 hatte er seine ideen von der zitat
stimulierten emissionen veröffentlicht
demnach erzeugt material das mit energie
bestrahlt wird lichtteilchen albert
einstein hatte seine theorie selbst nie
überprüft und erst einige jahre später
konnten wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler diese vermutung
bestätigen
die basis für die entwicklung des ersten
laser waren damit gelegt am ende gelang
es dann im jahr 1960 den ersten laser
fertigzustellen
ein rubin wurde hierbei als medium
genutzt um photonen freizusetzen auch
wenn man damals noch nicht so recht
ahnte wozu sich diese strahlen alles
nutzen lassen heute wissen wir
laserlicht ist licht in seiner
konzentrierten form
es strahlt 1000 kilometer weit und das
ohne aufzufächern laserlicht ist sogar
in der lage stahl zuschneiden 2018 gab
es den nobelpreis für drei
wissenschaftler die die laserphysik
revolutioniert hatten mit dabei unter
anderem der us physiker skin er ist
erfinder der optischen pinzette eine
methode um mit laserstrahlen bakterien
viren und selbst atome zu manipulieren
physikalisch gesehen haben das licht
einer glühlampe und ein laserstrahl nur
eine sache gemeinsam es handelt sich um
elektromagnetische strahlung doch das
war es auch schon
denn die unterschiede sind viel größer
laserlicht ist im gegensatz zu normalem
lampenlicht extrem geordnet und rein das
licht eines lesers ist auf einen
extremen engen ausschnitt des spektrums
beschränkt der großteil der laser ist
sogar monochrom a tisch und strahlt nur
in einer einzigen wellen dinge also in
einer einzigen farbe dadurch handelt es
sich bei dem laser um ein echtes
präzisionsinstrument seine wellenlänge
kann so genau eingestellt werden dass
die resonanzfrequenz eines atoms oder
moleküls getroffen wird so kann es nicht
nur aufgeheizt oder zum schwingen
gebracht werden sondern sogar in seiner
operation gebremst und seiner atome
abgekühlt werden
das ist paradox aber es funktioniert
erst vor kurzem hatten wir hier bei
pixum science im future über einen
spannenden erfolg der alpha
kollaboration am cern berichtet denn die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hatten es tatsächlich geschafft die
antiwasserstoff atome mit hilfe von
laserkühlung deutlich herunter zu kühlen
dabei wird die eigene bewegung der atome
abgebremst und zwar durch den einsatz
von laserstrahlen heber ist es wichtig
dass sowohl die frequenz als auch die
richtung des laser stimmen denn dann
können die photonen die eigene bewegung
der atome tatsächlich abbremsen so
gelang es im experiment tatsächlich die
antiwasserstoff atomen bis knapp über
dem nullpunkt herunterzukühlen
dabei standen diese dann fast still die
fachwelt hatte sich überrascht über
diesen erfolg derzeit können mit hilfe
dieser kühl methode von antiwasserstoff
spannende neue versuche mit antimaterie
ermöglicht werden
alle experimente die bisher mit normalem
wasserstoff durchgeführt wurden könnten
somit dann auch mit anti wasserstoff
durchgeführt werden auch die frage ob
antiwasserstoff der gravitation genau
unterliegt wie die normale materie
könnte so möglicherweise geklärt werden
und hier könnten möglicherweise
spannende erkenntnisse erwarten denn
wenn hier diskrepanzen offenbart würden
wäre dies tatsächlich ein hinweis auf
eine ganz neue physikalische
gesetzmäßigkeit und jetzt eben wird ein
spektakulärer erfolg in sachen laser
intensität aus südkorea gemeldet
dem forschungsteam gelang es tatsächlich
den bisherigen rekord in sachen laser
intensität zu knacken vereinfacht gesagt
wurden die laserpulse dafür zunächst
verstärkt dann geglättet und komprimiert
für die umsetzung notwendig waren somit
zum einen ein leser mit extrem hoher
leistung zum anderen muss dieser
laserstrahl dann auf einen möglichst
kleinen punkt fokussiert werden
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler aus südkorea nutzten
einen titan saphir leser 4 peter watt
stark mehrere verstärker wurden
eingesetzt um die energie
seiner laserpulse weiter zu erhöhen so
wurde der laserstrahl stück für stück
auf bis zu 28 cm durchmesser aufgeweitet
durch diesen schritt kam es aber auch
dazu dass die pools länge gedehnt wurde
diese musste dann also im anschluss von
einem nanometer wieder auf eine
femtosekunden länge komprimiert werden
eine weitere herausforderung für das
forschungsteam aus südkorea bei der
verstärkung waren wellenfront verzerrung
entstanden und diese mussten korrigiert
werden um diese steuereffekte
auszugleichen setzten die physikerinnen
und physiker definierbare spiegel ein so
gelang es tatsächlich den laserstrahl
glätten und auf kurze pulse zu bringen
schlussendlich musste dieser dann also
nur noch von einem parabolspiegel
fokussiert werden von 28 zentimetern
durchmesser konnte die strahlen weite
dadurch auf nur noch 1,1 mikrometer
reduziert werden die fachleute konnten
dann mit einer spezialkamera und
sensoren festhalten dass die laserpulse
eine intensität von 10 hoch 23 watt
aufweisen
und das bedeutet weltrekord um das mal
zu verdeutlichen ungerecht schaffte es
der leser also das äquivalent der
gesamten britischen sonnenstrahlung auf
nur zehn mikrometer zu bündeln oder
anders gesagt das gesamte sonnenlicht
das auf die erde trifft wird auf nur
einen hundertstel millimeter fokussiert
das forschungsteam schreibt zu diesen
spektakulären erfolg zitat der chor elst
peter bild leser ist damit der stärkste
liga der welt mit dieser intensität der
höchsten je erreichten können wir nun
ganz neue gebiete der experimentellen
forschung erschließen das könnte uns
helfen unseren wissens horizont zu
erweitern konkret meinen die
physikerinnen und physiker
beispielsweise die details der
quantenelektrodynamik aber ebenso auch
astrophysikalische vorgänger die wir
lange noch nicht durchblickt haben wie
genau können wir uns die kosmische
strahlung vorstellen und welche vorgänge
gehen im umfeld der mysteriösen
schwarzen löcher wo sich auf all diese
fragen könnten experimente mit einem
solchen lesers dem antworten geben es
ist wirklich unglaublich spannend wie
die forschung immer schneller immer mehr
fachrichtung große fortschritte erreicht
wir stehen vor einigen quantensprünge in
der wissenschaft welche das sind habe
ich in meinem buch per aufzug in den
weltraum ausführlich beschrieben wenn
euch also der und
etliche technologische fortschritt in
der nahen zukunft in der nahen zukunft
interessiert dann empfehle ich mein buch
per aufzug in den weltraum da geht es um
all diese quantensprünge leben in der
wissenschaft und es ist wirklich
frappierend wie vielen wissensgebieten
hier wirklich dramatische entwicklung zu
erwarten sind sei es quantencomputern
künstliche intelligenz raumfahrt in
china wird immer mehr geld in die
forschung gesteckt also auch da passiert
immer mehr
das ist wirklich unglaublich was in den
nächsten jahren also was wir alle
erleben noch werden was da alles
geschehen wird und ich glaube wir werden
viel zu staunen haben und ihr könnt
schon mal vorab staunen in meinem buch
per aufzug in den weltraum ansonsten bis
dann naja und vergesst nicht den podcast
auch zu abonnieren
bleibt dran